I didn't I'm it I think it should have
been exactly a pop psychologist for so
long because there's some amazing things
I teach introductory psychology I get a
chance to talk about all this fun stuff
I mean it is just a great course to
teach and I don't know why we have been
so ineffective or communicating it but
now there are many people who are
stepping up and communicating it it
might partially be due to the the way
it's been looked at from within academia
you know and frowned upon is selling out
and not serious and so on but I
genuinely believe that an important part
of what we do is communicating not just
to the people next door to us it's a
broader passing